foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled a
universal Day Zero infectious disease
testing strategy exploiting crispr-based
sample depletion and metagenomic
sequencing
this webinar is a part of the
microbiology virtual week event
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
gemco genomics for more information
about jump code gymnomics please go to
gemcogenomics.com
now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click submit
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speaker
John Armstrong VP of r d at gemco
genomics
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen John you may now
begin your presentation
hi I'm John Armstrong the VP of r d here
at Jump code genomics and today I'm
going to be talking to you about a
universal Day Zero infectious disease
testing strategy leveraging crispr-based
sample depletion and metagenomic
sequencing
our crisper clean technology essentially
removes uninformative molecules from NGS
libraries we want to shift sequencing
power to biologically relevant content
it slots very easily into a normal
Library prep workflow and essentially
helps to remove fragments prior to them
going onto a flow cell and reserving
real estate on the flow cell for
biologically relevant content and we've
been able to apply our crisper clean
technology here at Jump code to
multiple areas of of genomics
transcriptome profiling single cell
analysis infectious disease and
microbiome studies and today I'm going
to be showing you some data from a study
in infectious disease and at the end I'm
going to cover a new exciting product
that we have
foreign
so essentially
in most sequencing experiments with the
exception maybe of of genome assembly
and transcriptome assembly
we have a we have a needle in the
haystack problem so what's the
probability of finding the thing that we
want to find and
um you know we also have the secondary
problem that a small percentage of the
molecules that are in that Library
actually get sequenced and so we have a
saturation problem too so
you know after we do pcrs the
probability of finding that needle
decreases and um and then as we continue
to move through PCR we need to double
the amount of sequencing just to have
the same probability of finding that
needle
so really the thought process for our
product development was what if we could
turn that on its head
and simply say what happens when you
deplete the haystack
and then perform PCR amplification
and in this way we're able to enrich for
fragments of interest and then as we go
into PCR we have a much higher
probability of finding that needle and
also doing it with less sequencing
so we've been able to apply our
technology to transcriptome profiling
where our kit enables RNA sequencing
with ribo depletion meta transcriptomics
with RNA sequencing and ribotopletion in
mixed human and bacterial cells
single cell analysis for the 10x
chromium platform where we're able to
deplete approximately 50 percent of the
sequences and these sequences are not
even used by the software for cell
determination and finally our newest
application hosts depletion for human
microbiome studies and today I'll be
showing a study that we recently
submitted for review that used our meta
transcript metatranscriptomics kit
crispr clean plus and at the end we'll
show preliminary data for host depletion
using our crispr clean human DNA
depletion kit and a point to note one of
the really strong points of the crispr
system is how easily programmable it is
essentially you can cleave any Library
fragment that has a Pam site and we've
leveraged this programmability for the
development of the products that I'm
showing you here if you'd like to gain
Early Access to our crispr clean human
DNA depletion kit you can just send a
quick email to cells
jumpcodegenomics.com and again I will
present some data at the end and I'll
give you this email again
next I'm going to present data from a
paper we recently submitted titled a
universal Day Zero infectious disease
testing strategy leveraging crispr-based
sample depletion and metagenomic
sequencing
when we take a look at the timeline of
ID genome assembly and testing for the
recent covid-19 pandemic we see a
largely protracted timeline where the
first confirmed case was identified on
day Zero December 1st 2019 the first
public release of the viral genome
sequence occurred on day 42 the first
U.S eua approved rtpcr test was released
on Day 70 with a contamination issue and
by day 240 the U.S had a testing
capacity of approximately 800 000 tests
but we needed to be at 6 million tests
per day in this protracted timeline
could be catastrophic in the next
pandemic and thus our conclusion is
metagenomic NGS is the only technology
capable of day Zero diagnosis it
provides detection full genome sequence
co-infection and host response
before I show any data I first want to
show the experimental design we employed
we use covet samples for the study
design with the covet genome surveying
really as a proxy for any infectious
disease here but covet samples are
relatively easy to get hold of right now
and thus we used 83 nasopharyngeal
samples with 59 covet positive ranging
in cycle threshold from 16 to 39 and we
had 17 coveted negative samples each one
of these was split into three aliquots
one control and two depletion replicates
and each one of these went through
sequencing Library construction and
depletion and were sequenced at two by
150 bases and the data was analyzed with
either full read numbers or down sampled
to 80 million reads or 40 million
clusters
the resulting data went through a
five-prong analysis approach which is
shown shown here in the panel on the
right
using Kraken 2 for ribosomal RNA
composition czid and Kraken 2 for
taxonomy assignment species abundance
and identification of major species
the covet genome coverage variance and
clade identification was determined
using the workflow shown
antimicrobial resistance genes were
identified here labeled as AMR and
finally deg and go enrichment of human
genes using D Gen R
so I'm going to share data from each of
these analysis today
first we wanted to understand is there
an advantage to using crispr Clean Plus
when we could use something like an
alumina ribose0 plus workflow and so
what we did is we took five nanograms
and 50 nanograms of total RNA from human
fecal reference samples from xymo as
input into the crispr Clean Plus or
alumina ribose0 plus workflows so in
panel a you can see ribosomal RNA
alignment and the percentage of reads
aligning to ribosomal RNA species was
calculated for no depletion and depleted
sample libraries at the specified RNA
input and depletion was performed with
either the aluminum ribose0 plus which
is labeled here as ilmn or crispr Clean
Plus and the results show that crispr
clean plus is more effective at removing
ribosome RNA from metatranscriptomic
libraries than alumina ribose0 plus when
data is a rep is represented as a mean
of triplicates plus minus the standard
deviation
in panel B you can see the number of
bacterial species and this is sequencing
data from non-depleted or depleted
libraries treated with both of the
crisper clean and the Illumina kits and
you can see
when we analyze the data using Kraken to
Bracken workflows and calculated the
number of bacterial species with reeds
per million greater than 10 you can see
crisper Clean Plus enabled the discovery
of more bacterial species than alumina
ribo zero plus at both RNA inputs and in
panel C and D what we're looking at here
is the correlation of bacterial counts
between non-depleted and depleted
control samples so we're looking for
biasing here from the depletion and you
can see libraries were generated again
from the fecal reference control RNA and
subjected to a protocol with and without
crispr Clean Plus depletion and the
sequencing reads from both treatments
were processed using the Kraken Bracken
workflow again and the resulting
bacterial species read Counts from each
of the libraries were compared to
non-deplete from sorry the back the
species read Counts from depleted
libraries on the y-axis were compared to
none of depleted libraries on the x-axis
the bacterial species Counts from crispr
clean depleted libraries show a high
correlation with species Counts from
non-depleted libraries at both 5 and 50
nanogram RNA inputs with high R squareds
of 0.898 which is on the left panel and
an r squared of 0.9944 on the right
panel and this confirms that crisper
clean treatment produces little bias
with respect to the bacterial species
identification and recount measurements
so the previous slide was showing the
comparison of the crisper Clean Plus to
the aluminum ribo zero plus workflow and
that was done on on fecal reference
controls from zymo here is the actual
data from the study that I presented the
experimental design from the study I
presented uh several slides ago and here
with these those samples the coveted
positive and negative samples you can
see that
um what I'm showing here is the
ribosomal RNA composition before and
after crispr clean depletion of site a
specimens so these were site a being the
California site specimens so the
percentage of reads from all site a
libraries that align to different
species of RNA as shown before and after
depletion with the crisper Clean Plus
and following depletion an increase in
aligned reads for eukaryotic
non-ribosome RNA which is the dark blue
portion of the stack bar and the left
left panel bacterial non-ribosomal RNA
and viruses is observed there's a
decrease in aligned reads observed for
eukaryotic ribosomal RNA which is the
pink part of the bar and bacterial
ribosomal RNA purple of course this is
what we're targeting with the crisper
clean plus kit in panel B the percentage
of ribosomal RNA align reads calculated
as an average of all libraries from site
a was determined for bacteria in blue
and eukaryotes in purple and the
percentage of a line reads is shown with
and without crispr clean depletion and
crisper clean depletion you can see here
removes nearly all bacterial and you can
eukaryotic ribosomal RNA
and what we see is that the crispr Clean
Plus
depletion results in significantly
increased sensitivity and this slide is
showing sequencing read counts and
genome coverage of SARS cov2 in clinical
specimens with a range of CT values so
in panels a through C the number of
reads that align to the SARS covet II
genome determined from the crack and
workflow were calculated for
non-depleted blue and depleted purple
samples
the box and whisker plots were generated
for three cycle threshold bins where we
have a CT of less than 23. and we have a
CT of 23 to 30 and then finally a CT of
30 to 39.
and the values for the two depleted
sample replicates were averaged and
compared to single non-depleted samples
to provide paired paired values for the
wilcoxon signed rank test and the
results of that statistical tests
indicate that sequence read counts to
the SARS covet 2 genome are
statistically significantly higher with
crisper clean depletion than without
um and here we're also showing the Z
value the median of non-depleted and
depleted samples are shown and that's
shown in the upper left section of the
graph for each of the CT bins
in panels D through G you can see here
that the reach coverage across the
entire SARS covet 2 genome which is on
the x-axis is shown for four pairs of
depleted which is the purple line
and non-depleted the blue line samples
with a range of CT values
um
of 16.75 in D 22.18 and E
27.58 in F and 33.45 and G you can see
here that the coverage is consistently
higher for depleted samples than
non-depleted ones
here we show a heat map of the top 20
non-human species identified at sites A
and B the average log 2 reads per
million sequences are RPM were
calculated for non-human species in
clinical samples from both sites and the
top 20 species were identified from each
sample and they're listed alphabetically
here in the right column of the figure
on the left column is side A and the
right column is site B species the total
number of species in each column is
going to be greater than 20 because each
list represents the merger or the sum of
the top 20 species from many samples
log 2 RPM values are shown in each cell
red represents high and green represents
low
and species not detected are listed as
ND and species not expected to be shared
across samples are listed as n a and
denoted by white cells so the top 20
most abundant respiratory tract
commensals were 85 percent concordant
between site A and B uh however seven
species differed between sites and four
of these were patient-specific
respiratory pathogens and not expected
to be widespread thus they were excluded
from the percent concordance calculation
and three organisms differed between
sites and some of these discrepancies
may be caused by redalignment to
homologous sequences within a Genus or
between Genera and this is something
that we've seen in this data
and here we're showing a heat map of a
subset of samples from the previous
slide where we have Cova positive and
negative samples showing viral infection
and co-infection and the heat maps and
coverage depth and coverage breath plots
were generated for viruses only in a
subset of covet positive and negative
samples
the heat map colors on a log scale and
determine from the number of reads
aligning to the taxon in the ncbi ntnr
database so these are delineated as NT
reads per million and we used a
threshold cutoff of calling something
real of greater than or equal to 10
reads per million
you can see here that the crispr Clean
Plus assay is able to identify the
presence of viral material other than
covid and this is due to the hypothesis
neutral nature of the assay
we're designing guides to a remove
material not capture probes to go in and
specifically capture things out so we're
hypothesis neutral
and examples include uh down below
um actually sorry in the heat map
examples include co-infection of
rhinovirus C in covid positive sample
403 and rhinovirus a infection and covid
negative sample rcn8 additional viral
species are observed above above
threshold and other samples an example
of of this is gamma papillomavirus and
covet positive samples r04 and r05 and
malicea restricta and covet negative
samples C and five and then down in
panel B we show covid we took coveted
positive samples and we Spike them with
different ratios of four virus and two
bacterial species and here we're showing
uh the coverage plots for three of those
viruses or Ortho orthoreovirus zika and
influenza B and one bacteria Pro vitella
jejuni
and the genome coverage as I mentioned
can be generated for any organism in a
sample due to the hypothesis neutral
nature aspect of the crispr Clean Plus
assay
next we wanted to compare the
performance of crisper Clean Plus and
Next Generation sequencing for for covet
detection to rtqpcr at both sites A and
B samples with a CT of less than 35 were
processed with crispr clean NGS assay
and positive negative results compared
to rtq PCR results from the same samples
we then computed the values for
sensitivity specificity positive
predictive value and negative predictive
value and you can see those in the
contingency tables here these were
calculated for both sites A and B
samples and as you can see crispr clean
results are highly comparable to those
generated by rtq PCR
next we wanted to analyze the data to
see what genes and Pathways might be
involved in host response what we've
done here is we took the 15 covet
negative samples even though they may
have presented with a cold or other
symptoms and compared them to high viral
load coveted positive samples with CTS
less than 22 and these positive samples
comprise 29 samples we perform
differential expression analysis using
dgnr found a signature of 82 genes we
then looked at What gene ontology
pathway these genes were involved in and
you can see here on the left the
upregulated terms in the covet positive
samples strongly relate to the immune
system and in particular we have T Cell
chemotaxis a really high p-value pathway
for lymphocyte chemotaxis and also B
cell chemotaxis as an aside we're able
to Define these Pathways with no
underlying metadata other than CT values
we didn't have any metadata concerning
severity of the patient's response to
covid and no metadata for the negative
samples in fact if you remember the
coven negative sample that had
rhinovirus we also know that not all of
the negatives are true negatives and yet
still even with the lack of the meta
information and the pathogens that might
cause symptoms in the negatives we're
still able to find these statistically
significant upregulated immune Pathways
in covid positive samples
so as I've shown thus far
with the hypothesis neutral aspect of
the crispr Clean Plus coupled with Next
Generation sequencing you can see that
we have a really rich data set we've
been able to look at things in the
um in the non-host reads and we've been
able to investigate things in the host
reads as well one final thing that we
wanted to understand and investigate was
did we have the ability to identify
antimicrobial resistance genes in the
sequencing data and you can see here
that AMR genes were identified in
contigs that we had assembled from the
CZ ID output and the antibiotic class of
each gene was determined and the number
of samples harboring that Gene was
calculated that's in columns three and
four and then finally the average
percentage of sequence coverage and
identity to the AMR Gene is shown in
columns 5 and 6.
so in conclusion
crisper Clean Plus performs better than
ribo zero plus that was some of my early
slides and also the method of crispr
clean doesn't bias the bacterial and
viral representation in the sample if
you remember I showed XY plots early on
of depleted versus non-depleted with
extremely high r squared values
the ribosomal fragments from human and
bacterial bacterial are removed and
reeds are reassigned to informative
molecules and there this read
reassignment increases the coverage over
viral and bacterial genomes we don't
have to know what we're looking for we
can go in and see rhinovirus a
rhinovirus C gamma papillomavirus and
other things in these samples and they
don't just need to be coveted samples we
could be looking at
um RSV samples or another type of sample
pathogens and co-infections are easily
detectable
the sensitivity and specificity of
crisper Clean Plus with an NGS readout
is comparable to rtqpcr
that's important because although at
this point the NGS readout may take
longer the data set that's generated is
extremely rich in the the the data and
information we can gain from that is
uncomparable to rtq PCR
host data enables the investigation of
host response Gene signatures and
pathway enrichment and non-host data
enables the identification of
antimicrobial resistance genes invariant
IDs in the different viruses
so now I'm going to cover information
around our crispr clean human DNA
depletion kit
as I mentioned at the top of the
presentation we've just entered Early
Access for our crisper clean human DNA
depletion kit which removes human
genomic DNA from microbiome samples and
increases sensitivity of microbe
detection and genome coverage and so let
me walk you through a workflow for that
quickly
here's an overview of the crispr clean
technology when applied to host
depletion DNA is extracted from the
sample fragmented to approximately 20 KB
this DNA of course contains human and
microbial genomic DNA the DNA fragments
are unprotected and then cas9 and guide
specifically designed to Target only
human DNA are mixed with the genomic
fragments the enzymes cut at their human
Targets this then exposes non-protected
ends of the fragments allowing for
further reduction of the human genomic
content
the fragments that remain are now highly
enriched for microbial DNA content and
can simply go into your favorite DNA
Library prep and be sequenced on either
short read or long read systems and a
point to note here one of the strong
points of the crispr system is really
how easy it is to program the method to
essentially cleave any Library fragment
that has a Pam site
the guides we've designed to remove the
human genomic DNA are highly efficient
and the graph here shows that across
these five samples we're depleting our
Target regions at a rate greater than 99
percent and the depletion rate is shown
on the y-axis
um the state isn't shown here but
approximately 84 percent of the human
genomic Library fragments are removed to
some level by crispr and this is simply
driven by the way we've designed the
guides and the molecular methods
so next we wanted to understand how
depletion would affect the number of a
reeds aligning to the zymo control
organisms which is shown here with
percent reads aligned on the y-axis we
can see that when we remove human
Library fragments prior to sequencing
reeds are reassigned to not only what's
remaining of the human genome but also
the microbial genomes
and in this context you can see that the
percentage of reads aligning to the zymo
community control organisms it increases
in some greater than five-fold across
all of these samples
from around 1.5 percent of the total
reads in non-depleted samples to around
8.5 percent in the depleted samples and
this increase in reads and potential
increase in genome coverage equates to
an increase in detection capabilities
and reduced stochastic noise
so that ends into my presentation and
thank you for your attention if you'd
like to gain Early Access to our crispr
clean human DNA depletion kit please
email sales
jumpcogenomics.com and thank you again
and I'll now take any questions
foreign
thank you John for your informative
presentation we will now start the Q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
now let's get started
our first question
is someone who's I'm curious about the
upcoming human DNA depletion why is the
depletion step before Library prep
uh so we we we have that depletion step
um as at the very beginning of the of
the library process
um one of the main reasons for that and
I think it creates flexibility for
researchers is it allows them to perform
the depletion on that sample and then
they can take that sample and either go
off to short read sequencing if they're
wanting to investigate levels of of
bacteria or other um things in that
sample
um or they can go off to Long read
sequencing if they want to do a genome
assemblies or they want to do something
where they need longer contiguous reads
to be able to kind of parse through
different organisms so it creates a lot
of flexibility for the researcher and
for the system and
um you know it's it's a it's a simple
process it's it's just an an hour you
know an hour Hands-On time sorry an hour
time for the depletion minimal Hands-On
time and essentially you you you're able
to create you know a sequence a library
that's ready to sequence within a day
thank you for that
another question we have is how long is
the workflow for crispr Clean Plus
sure so the crispr Clean Plus product
um as I mentioned is uh depleting human
ribosomal and bacterial ribosomal
targeting
um 215 plus species of bacteria that is
a same workflow an hour long for the
depletion it happens during the library
process and again minimal Hands-On time
um that that that depletion is an
incubation so no Hands-On during the
incubation and again with the crisper
Clean Plus and a library and depletion
system you're able to have a sequencing
ready Library within a day there as well
and a follow-up to that as you touched
on what does the crisper Clean Plus
deplete
ah yeah so um just yeah so on the last
uh on the what I to repeat what I just
previously said was we're targeting that
um human uh ribosomal RNA as well as uh
bacterial ribosomal RNA and we've
um unlike other systems that have been
designed to say E coli and it's used as
a proxy for ribosomal for all of the
other bacterial species that are in
there and we know that that can be
somewhat lossy in that system or you
know designing something like E coli or
stapharias we've tried to go the extra
step further and um and design guides
that uh that are targeting
um specific ribosomal sequences from 215
plus
um or 200 plus I should say bacterial
species in the crispr Clean Plus um uh
in the crisper Clean Plus product
great thank you
um our next question is this applicable
for other applications
sure so
um yeah so that I'm going to assume that
the question centers around is the
depletion applicable uh for other
applications and and the answer is yes
in fact
um as I've talked about you know as I've
talked about already in some of the
questions here and in the presentation
we have guides that we have designed to
enable to deplete human genomic DNA also
we have crispr clean plus where we're
able to design guides and deplete human
ribosomal and bacterial ribosomal RNA
and so
um you know kind of
staying with that theme we also have
um panels that we're developing as well
so uh metabolic and cardiac and brain
panels that could be applied to things
like
um you know could be applied to bulk RNA
sequencing either short read or long
read we also have a single cell boost
kit that's a product that can be used
within the 10x single cell system and it
helps to
um increase the number of informative
reads by about twofold and uh and and if
and if cost is potentially one of your
levers then you could derive the same
answers that you would without using our
depletion system but using a sequencing
only half the reads for each of the
samples which may be maybe of interest
to to some researchers so we have other
things on the horizon as well that are
that are really interesting
and we also have the ability to do
custom so if somebody out there has a
specific system that their work working
on and they keep seeing things in there
that show up all the time for example
insulin or
globe and or other things like that we
have the ability to do custom designs
for people that then they're able to use
within their system and really to drive
the efficiency of of
um of fragment removal and and on the
flip side of that is
get the most amount of data for dollar
spent
thank you I think we're going to wrap up
with this last question also related how
long is the workflow for human DNA
depletion uh same thing here
um all of our workflows are for for
depletion at this point are are one hour
and as I mentioned with minimal Hands-On
time so
um you know the uh
and then like I said sequencing ready
library in a day
that's great
all right thank you again John for your
time today and your important research
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions I'd also
like to thank our sponsor jump code
genomics for sponsoring today's webinar
questions we didn't have time for and
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand for two years
until September 6 2024 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to then
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye